[موسيقى]
هذه
لحظة مهمة في التاريخ الأمريكي لتاريخ العالم
بالنسبة للبلد حيث تنزل كامالا هاريس
الدرج قريبًا لتصبح نائب الرئيس القادم
للولايات المتحدة وأريد
تدوين ملاحظة
حول اللون الذي ترتديه
حتى لا يكون  كما تعلمون ، لقد جربت ذلك لكن
كامالا هاريس ترتدي اللون الأرجواني وهو أمر
مهم جدًا بالنسبة لها عندما ترشحت
للرئاسة ، كان
أحد ألوان حملتها الانتخابية
باللون البنفسجي والأصفر ، وهذا إشارة
إلى شيرلي تشيشولم التي ترشحت للرئاسة
كامرأة سوداء.  منذ عقود
وألهمت حياتها المهنية السياسية 72
و 72 1972. وهكذا
ترى كافلا هاريس وهي تشير إلى
هذه اللحظة الرئيسية في التاريخ الأمريكي
للعديد من النساء
الملونات لشقيقاتها في نادي نسائي و alpha kappa
alpha المدمجة و  إنها تقف
هناك بجوار
مايك بنس نائب رئيس
الولايات المتحدة الحالي
، وقد تحدث الاثنان عبر الهاتف في
الأيام القليلة الماضية فقط ، لكن بخلاف ذلك لم يتحدثا
الكثير من
الاتصالات منذ أن أصبحت نائب
الرئيس المنتخب